[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy President Trump recently signed a
congressional resolution about the
events that took place in
Charlottesville Virginia in August in
the resolution the president is
expressing support for the
Charlottesville community rejecting
white nationalists white supremacists
the Ku Klux Klan neo-nazis and other
hate groups and urging the president and
the president's cabinet to use all
available resources to address the
threats posed by those groups now that's
a great idea am i right no sane person
supports the Klan or neo Nazis and this
should put an end to the spurious
brouhaha over Trump's post
charlottesville remarks but there's more
going on here
the key element of this resolution is
not its reference to white supremacists
white nationalists the Ku Klux Klan
neo-nazis the key element is the other
hate groups phrase the Klan and the
neo-nazis in reality as opposed to
leftist fever dreams are insignificant
and negligible forces their influence
and numbers are so negligible that it is
safe to say even after Charlottesville
that this resolution was most likely not
about them at all this resolution is
really all about those other hate groups
and here again we see the palsy hand of
the Southern Poverty Law Center the SPLC
has become notorious for classifying
legitimate organizations that dissent
from leftist ideology as hate groups the
SPLC recently refused to classify an
tyfa as a hate group it's noteworthy
that the resolution president Trump's
signed does not refer to an tyfa or to
any other violent left fascist groups
but only to the putative racist and
neo-nazi threat reacting to the manifest
unfairness of the SPLC s hate group list
forty-seven leaders who are unfairly
classified as members of hate groups
recently published an open letter to the
media asking journalists not to refer to
the SPLC as if it were
Oh arbiter of what dozen does not
constitute a hate group that letter of
which I was a signer read the SPLC is a
discredited left-wing political activist
organization that seeks to silence its
political opponents with a hate group
label of its own invention an
application that is not only false and
defamatory but that also in dangers the
lives of those targeted with it the
letter added we believe the media
outlets that have cited the SPLC in
recent days have not intended to target
mainstream political groups for violent
attack but by recklessly linking the
Charlottesville male to the mainstream
groups named on the SPLC website we are
left to wonder if another Floyd Lee
Corkins will soon be incited to violence
Corkins was the leftist fanatic who was
inspired by the SPLC hate group list he
went to the offices of the Family
Research Council intending to shoot its
officials and smear their faces with
chick-fil-a sandwiches he shot the
building manager who nonetheless was
able to stop him before he killed anyone
else the letter calling on journalists
to stop referring to the SPLC as a
reliable source also stated to associate
public interest law firms and think
tanks with neo-nazis and the KKK is
unconscionable and represents the height
of irresponsible journalism all
reputable news organizations should
immediately stop using the SPLC
descriptions of individuals and
organizations based on its own obvious
political prejudices and indeed that's
true but now that President Trump has
signed this resolution the question is
larger than simply one of news coverage
perfectly legitimate organizations are
falsely classified as hate groups and
lumped in with the KKK and neo-nazis by
the SPLC that well-heeled hate and smear
machine and the resolution states all
available resources of the United States
government will be used against hate
groups now keep in mind the fact that
when this resolution refers to hate
groups the SPLC doesn't have any
competitors its hate group list is the
only one around it's the only one
government
officials will be able to refer to when
they begin to put teeth into this
resolution that means the groups
opposing jihad terror and unrestricted
immigration and defending traditional
values could on the basis of this
resolution be targeted and destroyed by
the US government now that it has become
clear that a great many people who are
still entrenched in the Washington
bureaucracy are diehard Obama loyalists
who align perfectly with the else s
plc's political agenda this is a very
real possibility this resolution is more
of the left using Charlottesville as its
Reichstag fire moment to crush all
dissent Trump shouldn't have gone along
with this but once again the swamp
appears to have drained him
I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]